bonsoir et bienvenue très heureuse de
vous retrouver au sommaire de savaugarde
ce soir penser contre soi-même bonsoir
Nathan devt et merci beaucoup d'être
notre grand témoin ce soir philosophe
romancier éditeur et tenez-vous bien à
26 ans vous publiez votre 5e livre pensz
contre soi-même chez Albert Michel c'est
le récit autobiographique d'une
conversion à la philosophie l'histoire
personnelle d'un jeune homme qui veut
devenir Rabin et qui va finalement
complètement rompre avec la religion
juive et découvrir le doute c'est
foisonnant c'est très drôle aussi et
c'est courageux dans cette période où
tout le monde s'enferme dans ses
certitudes on va en parler longuement
tout à l'heure notre grand débat ce soir
comment peut-on mettre fin à la
dictature des écrans c'est l'une des
proposition du chef de l'État reprendre
le contrôle pour réguler l'exposition
des enfants Emmanuel Macron parle même
de restriction et d'interdiction mais
est-ce seulement possible nous en
débattons dans un instant avec mes
invités sur ce plateau enfin nos
affranchis ce soir le théâtre à l'école
fausse bonne idée nous dira Bertrand
Perrier le mot de la semaine c'est
autorité avec Mariette d'iggrand et puis
action planè la chronique écolo de Léa
Falco voilà donc pour le sommaire vous
me suivez Nathan de vert ça vous regarde
c'est
parti
[Musique]
après le réarmement civique et
démographique place donc au réarmement
face au numérique Emmanuel Macron veut
donc s'attaquer à l'addiction aux écrans
le danger est là on le sait surtout pour
les enfants mais reprendre le contrôle
c'est une autre paire de manches alors
quelles sont les solutions il y a-t-il
des modèles à suivre à l'étranger est-ce
à l'état de fixer les limites bonsoir
Fanta bereté bonsoir merci d'être là
vous êtes député renaissance de Paris il
y a une proposition de loi sur la
surexposition aux écrans qui a été votée
à l'Assemblée on en parlera elle doit
encore passer au Sénat bonsoir amine
benamina merci d'être là vous êtes
professeur de psychiatrie d'addictologie
à Paris saclcly chef de service à
l'hôpital Paul brous de Villejuif et
vous êtes l'un des membres de ce comité
d'experts qui a été mis en place par le
chef de l'État qui va rendre ses
conclusions fin mars sur le contrôle des
bonsoir Olivier Duris bonsoir bienvenue
vous êtes psychologue clinicien membre
de l'association 36 9 12 vous nous dirai
à quoi correspondent ces chiffres sur
les écrans pour les différents âges
recommandé aux enfants ou pas enfin
bonsoir François Saltiel merci d'être
avec nous journalistes et spécialistes
du numérique tous les matins 8h50 France
Culture avec un monde connecté Nathan
dev vert il est pour vous ce débat on se
souvient de votre roman Les liens
artificiels sur le métavert donc
n'hésitez pas à intervenir quand vous le
souhaitez on va commencer par planter le
décor le danger des écrans les
propositions du Président c'est dans le
recap de Bruno
donet et je me retourne pour vous
accueillir mon cher Bruno bonsoir à vous
bonsoir Miriam bonsoir à tous Alors vous
l'avez regardé cette épineuse question
des écrans pour les enfants et le moins
que l'on puisse dire c'est que vous êtes
ce soir partagé oui je suis un peu comme
l'écran qui est derrière moi myiam
divisé coupé en deux car j'ai bien
entendu le le président de la République
nous faire part de son nouveau sujet de
préoccupation passer du temps devant un
écran ça a un impact sur le
développement affectif sensoriel
cognitif d'un enfant voilà il est
inquiet pour la santé mentale de nos
enfants et plus particulièrement pour
celles des tout petits qui l'estime
beaucoup trop exposé on a des enfants de
2 ans et beaucoup qui passent parfois
plusieurs heures par jour devant un
écran alors je suis allé chercher les
chiffres et c'est vrai qu'ils sont assez
spectaculaires derri a un tout petit peu
moins d'un an santé publique France a
publié un rapport qui montre que dè
l'âge de 2 ans nos bambins se retrouvent
collé devant des écrans pendant
pratiquement 1h et ça tous les jours à 3
ans la durée passe à 1h 200 minutes à 5
ans c'est 1h34 et pour les adolescents
ceux qui ont entre 13 et 18 ans alors là
accrochez-vous bien car on dépasse les
5h quotidienne donc quand Emmanuel
Macron réclame un réarmement civique qui
passerait par davantage de maîtrise des
écrans on a forcément très envie d'être
d'accord avec lui et pourtant vous
l'avez dit en préambule vous n'êtes pas
très emballé et ben non je suis pas très
emballé parce que je me demande bien
comment un gouvernement qui je le
rappelle est totalement impuissant a
réglé la question par exemple de
l'exposition des mineurs à la
pornographie ou encore celle de la
modération des contenus sur les réseaux
sociaux pourrait bien s'y prendre très
concrètement pour empêcher des enfants
de se retrouver scotcher à des écrans
Emmanuel Macron a bien tenté de nous
l'expliquer mardi soir mais il m'a
semblé un peu empétré et donc il y aura
peut-être des interdictions il y aura
peut-être des restrictions il y aura
peut-être aussi des restrictions sur les
contenus voilà beaucoup peut-être mais
pas beaucoup de certitude et puis il y a
un autre sujet qui me contrarie beaucoup
Myriam il est cette fois de l'ordre du
libre arbitre des libertés individuelles
si vous préférez car mardi soir le
président de la République a précisé
ceci sur la base de recommandation que
font les experts que j'ai réuni la
semaine dernière nous déterminerons le
bon usage des écrans pour nos enfants
nous déterminerons le bon usage des
écrans pour les enfants alors ça c'est
un problème et pas un petit car qui est
ce nous quel légitimité a-t-il et en
vertu de quels éléments démocratiques un
état pourrait-il décider à la place des
parents de ce qui est adapté ou pas à
leurs enfants et puis tiens par exemple
est-ce que ça c'est bon pour les enfants
oui bonjour kiliian c'est Emmanuel
Macron à l'appareil vous êtes en
haut-parleur ça va très bien et vous ça
va super vous êtes en haut-parleur je
suis avec mcfl et Carlito là on sait pas
bref est-ce qu'on peut quand on est
président vouloir à la fois séduire les
jeunes en s'incrustant à l'intérieur de
leur smartphone le lundi et leur
interdire de regarder n'importe quoi dès
le mardi la question est vertigineuse
hein et elle a de quoi comme le montre
cette très belle illustration que j'ai
vu dans Libération hier matin nous à
tout entier merci beaucoup Bruno Donnet
avant d'enevenenir aux solutions aux
esquisses de de propositions de du chef
de l'État je voudrais me tourner vers
vers vous vers les médecins Abine
benamina qu'est-ce qu'on sait
précisément aujourd'hui de la
surexposition des écrans qu'est-ce que
vous observez dans les cabinets à
l'hôpital dans vos consultations sur
cette addiction notamment chez les
enfants alors je vais m'exprimer en tant
que clinicien et puis j'auraai peut-être
l'occasion de répondre à vos questions
en tant que co-président de la
commission que le président a installé
une petite semaine alors en tant que que
psychiatre addictologue moi je vois des
adolescents et puis j'ai des contacts
avec mes mes collègues pédiatres qui
montrent ce qu'a montré votre collègue
une surexposition une consommation qui
explosé des écrans pour des raisons
simples c'est un outil qui est devenu
indispensable à la fois pour les adultes
et en même temps une forme d'AD duvent
ou bien une forme de substitut
éducationnel et d'occupation et aussi un
canal un canal pédagogique pour les
enfants alors à la fois à l'intérieur de
la famille mais aussi à l'extérieur
l'école aussi utilise les écrans donc
l'idée c'est très clairement de voir
s'il y a de la nocivité parce que moi je
suis médecin s'il y a de la nocivité à
la consommation mais quels sont les
effets concrets les symptômes il y a des
troubles de comportement du langage le
président parle de problèmes sensoriel
et même affectif alors les pédiatres
rapportent cont l'exposition est précoce
disons entre 0 2 3 ans quelques
difficultés cognitives quelques retard
évidemment à l'apprentissage certaines
théories qui ne sont pas relayés par la
littérature scientifique parle même de
d'attitude psychotique autistique
autistique évidemment tout ça concourt à
la possibilité d'avoir des voix qui sont
contradictoires sur la question des
écrans une chose est certaine c'est que
les écrans ont une compétition avec le
sommeil ont une compétition avec le
sport joue une compétition avec
l'éducation et joue une compétition avec
la sociabilité et lorsqu'on va au bout
au bout du bout ben vient me voir en
tant qu'adidictologue parce qu'on
devient dépendant à la fois de l'objet
du contenu ça c'est une réalité en
revanche quand on entend le Président
c'est exprimé comme quelqu'un qui ne
sait pas forcément lorsqu'il dit
peut-être peut-être peut-être parce que
prent très clairement il est prudent
pour des raisons simples sinon il aurait
pas mis en place une commission il
attend de manière très transparente
comme nous tous y compris moi membre de
la commission ce que la consultation et
les auditions va nous amener on est
conscient qu'on a affaire à quelque
chose qui est très touffu avec des
positions très souvent péromptoir le
plus souvent sans rationnel scientifique
au doigts mouillés et qui font qui
deviennent autorité sans
réalité d'impact sur la quantité et la
qualité de l'exposition à l'écran
Olivier Duris le le diagnostic du
praticien de terrain le clinicien
qu'est-ce qu'il observe B alors il y a
le clinicien il y a aussi le chercheur
du coup et c'est vrai que je rebondis
sur ce qui a été dit qu'il faut éviter
de tomber dans la panique morale par
exemple quand on entend parler d'autisme
ou de choses comme ça et de voir que les
études scientifiques ne parlent pas par
exemple d'autisme sur ce planl par
contre ce qui est intéressant c'est que
les études scientifiques parlent d'une
chose aujourd'hui aussi c'est de voir
que la question de la surexposition doit
être pris comme un facteur parmi tant
d'autres ça veut dire que en fait quand
on remarque à côté aussi la question de
la disponibilité des parents la question
de l'accessibilité au jouets la question
du fait de pouvoir faire d'autres
activités à l'extérieur dans la ville ou
des choses comme ça on se rend compte en
fait finalement que il y a pas que les
écrans qui vont avoir en fait un impact
sur le développement de l'enfant et
souvent en fait c'est un peu trop facile
que de penser que l'écran danger parmi
d'autres exactement et en fait on se
rend compte même que et ben lorsqu'on le
prend en dehors des autres facteurs et
ben en fait finalement son impact est
pas si important que ce qu'on peut
penser alors il y en a un mais en fait
c'est vraiment pris avec tous les autres
facteurs que là ça devient important
est-ce que déjà sur la capacité de
concentration sur le temps d'attention
ça je crois que c'est relativement avéré
quel que soit d'ailleurs les âges et
bien en fait ce qui est avéré surtout
c'est le fait que que en effet quand il
y a une surexposition aux écrans on va
pouvoir voir une corrélation avec
ensuite des impacts plus tard qui
pourrai y avoir par exemple sur
l'apparition du langage par exemple sur
le surpoids ou autre mais encore une
fois qu'on se rend compte surtout que
c'est vraiment la question de
l'accompagnement des activités annexes
ou autres et c'est pour ça d'ailleurs
qu'aujourd'hui on parle même de
technoférence parentale ça veut dire
l'exposition des parents eux-mêmes face
aux écrans et pas forcément l'enfant
parce que qu'est-ce qui vient être
important finalement c'est la question
de la relation qui va se passer et des
échanges de regard et diile voilà de se
passer un d'un écran can quand on est
mineur quand les parents sont scotchés
sur leur smartphone je vous donne la
parole dans un instant mais pour se
figurer les choses je vous propose ce
reportage on parlait d'enfants qui ne
parl pas regardez et bien c'est un
reportage qui a été tourné par Hélène
Bonduel qui a pu assister à une
consultation pédiatrique dans une unité
spécifique de l'hôpital jeanverdier
regardez on y va allez viens vas-y on y
va cette pédiatre a une consultation
unique en France à l'hôpital sur la
surexposition aux
écrans à 3 ans Maya ne parle quasiment
pas ça a commencé vers quel âge vous
Dirz à peu près là vous dites vers 3
mois 6 mois 3 mois elle était vraiment
devant la télé à 3 mois ouais est-ce que
c'est allumé pendant les repas est-ce
que vous mangez avec les écrans ou oui
est-ce que vous l'utilisez pour la
calmer euh ou le médecin s'appuie sur un
questionnaire spécifique pour évaluer sa
consommation et sa dépendance aux écrans
résultat 5 à 6 he par
jour ça impacte vraiment de nombreux
domaines que ça soit le comportement la
gestion de des humeurs la gestion des
frustrations qui est importante quand on
est petit et surtout l'apprentissage et
l'entrée dans le langage et dans les
interactions ouais tu veux faire le
docteur
S
langageér qui comme Maya ne font que
répéter ce qu'ils ont vu dans les
dessins animés effectivement les
différentes applications YouTube ou ce
que vous voulez ont tendance à mettre
l'alphabet en faisant croire un peu aux
parents que c'est comme ça qu'on va
faire des progrès et du coup on met les
choses à l'envers c'est-àdire qu'on
apprend l'alphabet à 3 ans mais on ne
parle pas encore bien à 3 ans et en fait
moi ce que je veux c'est que votre
petite fille elle apprenne le mot pull
le mot chaussette le mot pomme le mot
camion les mots du quotidien d'accord et
c'est ça
vaircoupcoup pour que le langage
s'installe qume et pour cela le message
de la pédiatre est radicale arrêt total
des écrans voilà avant 3 ans arrêt total
des écrans Fanta ber quand on voit ça on
se dit elle est où la grande campagne de
prévention à l'image de du tabac et de
l'alcool au moins ça pourquoi on l' pas
ben je pense que depuis quelques temps
c'est vrai qu'on essaie de poser des
mots sur ces ces mots qu'on vient de
qu'on vient de voir euh maintenant je
pense que justement le le président
prend un bras le corps cette
problématique parce que que ce soit à
l'école que ce soit nous en tant que
citoyens en tant que parents en fait ce
problème nous saute que j'ai envie de
vous dire au visage mais en fait on ça
veut dire quoi responsabiliser les
parents ouindre les familles je pense
qu'on doit dans un premier temps tous
être responsabilisés moi ce qui m'étonne
aujourd aujourd'hui moi j'ai une fille
qui a 20 ans mais quand les parents
rentrent avec des enfants en basage dans
un restaurant les autres adultes ont
plutôt tendance à se dire j'espère qu'il
va y avoir un écran et qu'ils vont être
occupés parce qu'ils ont pas envie
d'avoir des interactions avec eux
c'est-à-dire qu'on a mis les enfant à
distance on veut pas qu'il fasse de
bruit pour pas qu'il ne fasse de bruit
on leur donne une tablette on leur donne
un écran on veut pas dans le TGV être à
côté d'enfant qui vont jouer avec des
jouets qui font du bruit alors que leur
mettre des écouteurs et leur mettre un
des on a tous vu des bébés dans la
poussette avec sm dans dans le Cady à
Carrefour enfin à Carrefour au champ et
cetera donc en fait c'est un problème de
société c'est où est la place de
l'enfant en 2024 est-ce qu'on lui permet
de jouer avec ses joujous qui font
énormément de bruit est-ce qu'on lui
permet de vivre et de se raconter des
aventures avec des legos plutôt qu'avec
des écrans pour le mettre en sommeil
pour le mettre en veille et pouvoir se
concentrer sur nos activités
exactement où est euh la place de
l'écran dans la société et et où poser
le curseur et qui doit poser ce curseur
François Saltiel ce problème au fond
tout tous les pays du monde ils sont
confrontés il y a des modèles à suivre
il y a des limites posées par les États
est-ce qu'elle vous semble légitime
qu'est-ce qui se fait en Europe on pense
à la Chine aussi évidemment régime
autoritaire qui va très loin oui oui on
sait que la Chine a à Somé des
interdictions je crois que c'était 45
minutes notamment pour l'usage des jeux
vidéos mais je pense que là où il y a
peut-être un petit problème de
définition dès le départ c'est quand on
parle d'écran on parle de quoi en fait
c'est est-ce que l'écran c'est lire le
livre de Nathan de ver qu'on peut lire
sur un écran est-ce que c'est aller sur
Wikipédia pour s'informer est-ce que
c'est regarder une série un film est-ce
que c'est aller sur les réseaux sociaux
est-ce que c'est la tablette que on
utilise à l'école aussi hein dès le
collège donc je trouve que il y a une
forme de diabolisation aussi de l'écran
or l'écran c'est Multiple c'est de de
multiples contextes d'usage et
d'utilisation et je pense que chaque
contexte mérite une explication sont
clair et des règles claires lorsqu'on
parle des réseaux sociaux par exemple
effectivement on sait bien que les
réseaux sociaux dans la manière dont ils
sont conçus par les gafem on est dans
une économie de l'attention qui cherche
à la capter et c'est ça qui va être
finalement le modèle économique d'un
réseau social et on sait aujourd'hui on
a mis du temps à s'en rendre compte et à
réagir que la manière dont le réseau est
designé il est fait pour faire en sorte
qu'on perde même notre intention
première de ce pourquoi on y va pour
qu'on y reste le plus longtemps possible
et devenir finalement l'objet d'un
ciblage publicitaire donc c'est sûr vous
faites bien d'ailleurs de distinguer
parce que l'objet les les contenus c'est
très différent mais n'empêche qu'il y a
un objet qui est la porte d'entrée pour
les enfants si on reste sur les enfants
qu'est-ce qu'on fait à l'étranger alors
est-ce que est-ce que il y a déjà des
pistes et est-ce qu'elles sont efficaces
alors à l'étranger on on peut parler
justement de de la Suède qui était un
cas intéressant notamment à l'école qui
depuis plus d'une dizaine d'années avait
décidé de passer par exemple en tout
numérique en essayant d'arrêter les
manuel scolaire papier pour les
remplacer justement par des écrans et
par des tablettes ce qui peut être une
idée pourquoi pas intéressante parce
qu'on on se dit que finalement le monde
aujourd'hui est un monde numérisé et
qu'on il faut tout de suite donner aux
enfants les outils qui vont être ceux de
leur quotidien au travail et ils sont
revenus un peu sur leur décision alors
c'est pas très clair dans la manière
dont il correllent la baisse du niveau
justement des enfants en Suède par
rapport à ce tout numérique mais
néanmoins ils reviennent finalement au
papier donc là on a un exemple suédois
tout numérique avec un retour finalement
au papier vous avez évoqué la Chine mais
la Chine c'est quand même un cas très
particulier et assez paradoxal
d'ailleurs parce que je rappelle que
TikTok est tout de même une application
chinoise donc on a d'un côté ti la Chine
qui va servir de TikTok comme un outil
de soft power pour essayer d'avoir et
bien la main par rapport au concurrents
américain sur une forme de jeunesse
mondiale et installer leurs standard et
de l'autre essayer de préserver une
population en considérant que cet écran
est dangereux donc on voit bien en tout
cas par si on veut faire une échelle
internationale qu'en ce moment on est en
Europe dans une volonté de reprise en
main législative on l' vu avec des
règlements européens qui sont rentrés en
vigueur à la fin du mois d'août le DSA
le DMA on l'a vu à l'échelle nationale
avec la la loi de sécurisation de
l'espace numérique qui a été mené par
par le ministre du numérique donc il y a
quand même cette idée de se dire pour
une fois euh régulation il est posé il
est pas considéré comme impossible à
mettre en œuvre on va voir à quelle
échelle évidemment compliqué euh un
petit mot un petit mot je suis tout à
fait d'accord avec la manière dont vous
présentez les choses c'est-à-dire que
une révolution technique d'abord on peut
pas l'empêcher on peut pas euh si vous
voulez de par la volonté politique
l'annuler c'est le fameux ceci tuas cela
de Victor Hugo le livre a remplacer
l'édifice c'est un autre rapport à la
culture c'est un autre rapport au savoir
maintenant la question est qu'est-ce
qu'on en fait et alors ça a peut-être
changé depuis mais quand j'étais au
lycée au collège je me souviens que il y
avait pas vraiment d'utilisation de
l'éducation nationale des écrans sauf
euh parfois la salle informatique on
faisait des choses mais c'était pas
passionnant et que donc les écrans
c'était ce qu'on avait dans la poche et
dans notre tête c'était des objets de
divertissement c'était pas du tout des
objets de savoir et on était pas du tout
spécialement euh éduqué à une
utilisation et vous avez mentionné le
fait qu'il y a euh un côté polymorphe
des écrans que euh l'écran c'est avant
tout uneû une bibliothèque infinie qu'on
peut avoir dans son ordinateur dans son
téléphone et cetera et il me semble
alors je dis pas ça pour la petite
enfance he mais pour l'adolescence qu'il
faudrait qu'il y ait à l'école au
collège au lycée vraiment une éducation
mais très très forte à à une utilisation
même intellectuelle pédagogique
didactique de l'objet écran alors vous
qui voyez les ravages si je peux
utiliser ce terme euh dans dans vos
pratiques de de médecin qu'est-ce que
vous attendez est-ce que déjà vous vous
dites que c'est un problème sociétal qui
mérite que l'État s'emmèle
alors contrairement ce qu'on
croit lorsque l'État se mêle des
questions qui peuvent apparaître comme
étant des questions dans dans l'esace
privé elle n'a aucune force de pouvoir
la faire appliquer à l'intérieur des
maisons c'est la raison pour laquelle on
parle pas de loi on Mme parle de
recommandation et la recommandation
combien même on la suit pas c'est un
c'est une aide éducationnelle c'est un
un c'est une c'est une orientation c'est
un peu le contrôle parental ça existe
aujourd'hui parental temp ça vous le
voyez ça marche est que gens vous avez
des innovations techniques dans
lesquelles les Barents ne sont pas elles
existent mais les Barents ne les utilise
pas c'est la raison pour laquelle dans
la commission il y a un volet évidemment
très clair de réflexion que l' qu'on va
mener sur l'environnement si vous mettez
en place des recommandations ou alors
des lois ou bien des repères si vous
n'intégrez pas ça si vous n'intégrez pas
l'adulte et les parents ça ne marchera
pas je voudrais dire aussi un élément
intéressant et qui me semble intéressant
important qu'a dit le président il
expliqué aussi un élément qui est très
inquiétant c'est la notion de vérité
contre vérité et la notion de
citoyenneté l'écran devient il a dit
bonjour les complotiste la nouvelle
génération qui vientoui et c'est très
important parce qu'on le voit dans la
pratique à titre personnel moi je le
vois tout ce qui sort de l'écran est
crédible et ne fait pas l'objet de
critique de la part des nouvelles
générations tout ce qui vient de
l'adulte et qui est dans le contact j'ai
envie de dire physique est plus suspect
et ça ça pose problème tout ce qui est
écrit dans les réseaux sociaux ne
souffre souffre très peu de de critique
et ça c'est aussi c'est un élément
véhicul d'accord avec Nathan de sur
l'éducation complètement et qui doit
faire l'objet d'une réflexion de la part
de la Commission qui sera le cas ça
n'est pas simplement un un produit nocif
sur l'éducation l'évolution ou
l'addiction ça c'est important c'est un
vrai projet de société aussi derrière
Olivier Duris c'est quoi la règle des 3
6 9 12 et cette association qui porte ce
nom elle s'appelle 369 12 plus he
toujours plus d'écran toujours plus de
questions donc voilà et l'objectif de
cette association qui a été créée par
STIs FR en 2008 c'est de pouvoir faire
de la prévention et de l'information
auprès des jeunes et des parents et des
professionnels sur la question des
écrans leur côté positif et aussi les
risques qui peuvent en être liés et j'ai
envie de rebondir sur ce qui a été dit
tout à l'heure parce que en effet ce qui
est important c'est que on le disait au
début il y a un consensus scientifique
sur la question des écrans mais il
manque un consensus de valeur un petit
peu et c'est là où les discours
divergent et le fait que il y ait un
discours de l'État qui puisse venir pour
pouvoir partager en fait des
recommandations ou autres déjà c'est
intéressant parce que ça permettrait
enfin de mettre un consens consens
là-dessus et aussi parce que comme je le
disais au début je pense que le rôle de
l'État c'est aussi de comprendre que
c'est intéressant de se détacher des
écrans et de se rendre compte par
exemple que il y a déjà une disparité
socio-économique par rapport à la
surexposition aux écrans et que bah il y
a aussi quelque chose qui relève de la
politique de la ville et de la politique
de santé publique proposer par exemple
plus d'actions ou plus d'activités pour
les familles desœuvrés proposer aussi un
accompagnement pour les parents qui sont
en difficulté disparité socio-économique
pour être très clair plus on est
défavorisé plus on est exposé exactement
alors juste pour préciser 3 6 9 12 pas
d'écran avant 3 ans pas de console alors
ça c'est ce qu'on pense au début sauf
qu'en fait ça a changé depuis et
maintenant c'est vraiment par exemple
avant 3 ans jouer parler arrêter la
télévision des choses comme ça
l'objectif c'est de pas chercher à
mettre de pas de pas de pas de parce
c'est que j'ai lu hein sur le site pas
de console avant 6 ans pas d'internet
avant 9 ans internet seul à partir de 12
ans tout ça vous dites repè maintenant
on parle de balise en fait parce que
justement l'objectif c'est pas de mettre
de contraintte parce que les discours
négatifs fonctionnent que les discours
positifs et parce que on se rend compte
en fait que le plus important c'est
justement d'échanger et de s'amuser avec
son enfant et donc par exemple plutôt
que de dire pas de télé on dit bah jouez
parle regardez votre enfant et arrêtez
la télévision et en fait c'est ça qui
est important aussi c'est la manière
dont on parle aussi et dont on s'adresse
donc si je vous écoute il faut informer
il faut éduquer mais pas forcément
légiférer fantérité mais je pense que
pas restreindre pas interdire les
Français n'aime pas l'interdiction d'une
manière générale donc si on veut les
frustrer et faire en sorte qu'il qu'il
soit en front là-dessus je pense que
c'est ce qu'il faudrait faire
aujourd'hui je peux pas vous dire si on
va pas légiférer on a un c'est lui qui
décide c'est le conseil d'expert avec
ses recommandations nous on on sera là
pour agir s'il y a besoin de venir
rajouter un petit quelque chose parce
que peut-être qu'on a quelque chose
auquel on n' pas pensé par contre je
pense que le fait d'en parler le fait de
se dire qu'on a des philosophes le fait
d'avoir des plateaux aussi télé où on
vient se confronter confron onter les
idées sur ce sujet permet aussi à toute
la société parce que pour moi c'est
générationnel et c'est aussi le travail
des parents des des amis et cetera de
prendre conscience qu'il a un problème
que peut-être que votre enfant n'est pas
touché parce que vous vous avez mis un
certain nombre de limites et que ça
fonctionne très bien dans votre foyer
tant mieux je ferai un petit coucou à
certains hommes politiques qui ont pris
la parole sur ce sujet d'ailleurs mais
dans certains foyers ça ne fonctionne
pas et dans le cadre du programme des
1000 jours il y avait une partie du
programme qui avait vocation aussi à
sensibiliser ces jeunes parents pour
leur dire on vous dit pas que vous allez
mal faire on vous dit simplement qu'il y
a un danger et que vous pouvez l'éviter
en faisant tel ou tel usage donc là
c'est le rôle je crois de la puissance
publique et c'est également accompagner
ceux qui sont au service des familles je
pense aux aidents sociaux certain nombre
exactement aussi mais de de les
accompagner dans les prises de parole et
justement dans les conseils à donner à
ceux qui ont besoin françoisel oui
justement par rapport à la question de
la la puissance publique je pense qu'on
peut distinguer aussi qui est l'ordre de
la sphère intime et puis peut-être de
l'ordre de de l'écosystème euh c'est
pour ça que quand on entend
effectivement le président de la
République dire pourquoi pas des
interdictions quand on reprend justement
la chronique qui a ouvert cette émission
et encore une fois le modèle chinois je
pense que personne ici n'a envie qu'on
nous impose alors attention il y a une
loi qui va expliquer qu'on peut pas avir
plus d'écran après 22h dans les foyers
sinon on va vous pointer du doigt je
veux dire c'est c'est pas cette
société-là dont on a envie c'est pour ça
que le modèle chinois il est plutôt
toujours un peu effrayant et je pense
pas qu'il doit être qu'il doit être pris
comme modèle à ce niveau mais vous
pensez que l'État c'est son rôle
bah non je je pense pas que ça soit son
rôle après et c'est pour pour vous il y
aurit une atteinte aux liberté bah
disons que ça ça touche à l'intime et
c'est vrai que le risque de ça c'est un
peu la culpabilisation aussi des parents
de se dire bah finalement on doit pas
agir comme ça on agit mal et cetera
alors que bon déjà même en tant que
adultes ou en tant que même ceux qui
sont parfois même à l'origine des lois
et des conceptions sont pas non plus
irréprochables dans notre manière dont
on aborde justement les écrans par
contre là où je pense que la puissance
publique est nécessaire c'est pour
essayer de tenter de réguler certaines
dérives vous avez évoqué tout à l'heure
les réseaux sociaux et donc la D
information les absences et la déférence
de la modération là je pense que
effectivement là il y a une nécessité
pour que la puissance publique fixe des
limites en disant voilà telle entreprise
telle multinationale ne peut pas
siamment offrir un service à plus de
tant de milliards d'utilisateurs pas
mettre les moyens nécess tap au
poronnaie sur les contenus et les
algorm algoritthmes parce qu'
effffectivement quand on parle des
réseaux sociaux c'est toujours un peu
compliqué parce que sur les réseaux
sociaux on a autant LCP que le monde que
des agents de la désinformation donc la
question c'est comment on va arriver à
avoir une transparence de ces
algorithmes là parce qu'on sait
qu'aujourd'hui il fonctionne par une
sorte de viralité des contenus qui sont
les plus sensationnels qui provoquent le
plus d'engagement et généralement ce
sont pas les contenus les plus vérifiés
ou du moins qui indique justement des
informations qui le sont donc là oui là
je pense qu'il faut exiger une
transparence des algorithmes je pense
qu'il faut enlever les nudge les d
partern tous ces mots un peu obscurs et
ça cette volonté elle existe au niveau
européen aujourd'hui elle est à l'œuvre
après elle est complexe parce que vous
vous attaquez quand même à des
entreprises qui ne sont pas qui sont
étrangères qui sont hors sol au niveau
européen et c'est tout le jeu qui est en
train de jouer l'Europe en disant voilà
on est tout de même un marché et ce
marché si vous voulez continuer y
exercer vos fonction vous devez
respecter certaines règles amine benam
vous vous êtes sur quelle ligne vous
allez pas nous donner les
recommandations mais c'est vrai que
comme vous faites partie vous êtes
co-présidente de cette cette commission
d'experts on a un peu envie de savoir
qu'est-ce que vous allez proposer alors
j'ai une définition qui est la mienne
qui est celle qui a conduit la plupart
de mes régulièrement la pratique et qui
fait avancer mes patients on avance plus
par la compr que par la punition
d'accord c'est un c'est une base la
science comportementale le Président il
a dit et vous l'avez senti ça a été très
bien dit d'entrée de jeu lorsqu'il il
était en train d'énoncer l'interdiction
peut-être peut-être à la fin peut-être
non peut-être oui il se posait la même
question non c'est pas flou c'est il
sait pas il sait pas il nous a demandé
et lorsqu'on s'est vu il a constitué un
comité dans lequel vous avez deux
médecins et les huit autres personnes ne
sont pas des médecins ce sont des
scientifiques ce sont des
épidémiologistques ce sont des personnes
qui travaillent sur le monde du
numérique et et ce sont des ce sont
aussi des des des sociologues et des
juristes donc on sait parfaitement qu'on
va être confronté à quelque chose
d'extrêmement compliqué et et clairement
il a dit je sais très bien que ça ne
sera pas juste une dimension française
il faudra réfléchir européen aussi et
donc on sait parfaitement qu'il y a un
jeu parti on va auditionner probablement
aussi les gars femmes les grandes
entreprises on sait qu'il y a quelque
chose d'extrêmement ténu et je répète
j'ai pas le sentiment que dans cette
commission on va émettre des
recommandations pour pour altérer la
liberté des uns et des autres de la même
manière qu'on sait qu'il faut pas fumer
qu'il faut pas dépasser de ver d'alcool
par jour sur 10 jours et faire un arrêt
de 48h et ça ne choque pas parce qu'on a
on a les résultats des études
scientifiques qui montrent qu' à partir
d'un certain seuil on est malade on peut
aussi émettre des recommandations sur
quelque chose qui viennent faire
rraction dans notre vie que sont les
éc sans pour aant sans pour autant
altérerérer ou bien entrer dans
l'intimité des foyers des Français oui
vous qui avez écrit espace fumeur qui la
liberté individuelle vous pensez que
l'État n'a n'a pas son rôle à simisser à
fixer les limites au sein des foyers oui
je pense que c'est pas que c'est pas son
rôle mais qu'en revanche l'État a raison
là de mettre la question des écrans
vraiment en premier plan la question
qu'il faut se poser quand même c'est
quelle société nous prépare ce qu'on
appelle la révolution numérique toute
révolution technique a des conséquences
culturelles moi j'aime beaucoup c'est
vous savez c'est la théorie de régist de
BR que l'invention des routes en Europe
a engendré le roman que l'invention de
de la presse a engendré le socialisme et
et on pourrait se demander alors voilà
ça nous amène où cette invention des
écrans et il me semble qu'il y a une
chose qui est centrale pour les jeunes
pour les adolescents et pour les adultes
c'est que finalement la société dans
laquelle on est est une société de
démocratie totale notamment sur le plan
de la parole jusqu'à il y a encore 40 50
ans il y avait une une démarcation entre
des citoyens qui étaient des citoyens
actifs qui avaient le droit d'avoir une
parole publique et la quasi totalité des
autres citoyens qui avait une parole
privée et quand il parlait c'était
uniquement entre amis en famille et
cetera là tout le monde peut avoir droit
à une parole publique et ça évidemment
que c'est un bouleversement total
notamment pour les adolescents pour les
jeunes pour les étudiants dans leur
insertion dans la citoyenneté dans la
société le risque qu'il peut y avoir
derrière cette émancipation l'aliénation
que vous pointez du doigt et ben
évidemment c'est quand cette parole
publique elle est cour circuité que ça
crée ces phénomènes de post vérité de de
complottisme et cetera merci beaucoup
peut-être un dernier mot de la député
sur la majorité numérique à 15 ans ça
c'est voté aussi pensez que ça peut être
efficace ben je pense que oui
effectivement donc ça va dans le bon
sens pour moi et tant qu'Alex à
auront leur mot à dire il faut quand
même qu'on puisse protéger certains la
loi numérique ça fait pas bon ménage
ouiit il y a peut-être une loi qu'on
devrait tous appliquer c'est essayer
surtout la loi de la compréhension et
c'est pour ça que je rejoins cette
nécessaire éducation numérique parce
qu'on a tous dans les dans les mains des
outils qu'on comprend pas très bien et
il y a une nécessité d'ouvrir la machine
pour l'expliquer et donc déjà en premier
temps en parler c'est ce que vous faites
ce soir et ensuite essayer d'en
comprendre les rouages et pour ça il
faut passer et bien par une indication
pour rentrer à l'intérieur des machines
pour mieux les comprendre merci on
s'arrête là professeur Benyamina vous
êtes invité le jour de la remise de la
la commission d'experts merci à vous
vous restez avec moi Nathan de vert dans
une dizaine de minutes les parties Pride
nous affranchi ce soir le regard de
maître Bertrand Perrier sur le théâtre
obligatoire au collège autorité c'est le
mot de la semaine de Mariette d'iggrand
et puis de quoi nous parlez-vous Léa
Falco dans Action planè on parle de
sport d'hiver et de redirection
écologique des stations de ski à tout à
l'heure les amis mais d'abord penser
contre soi-même c'est à livvre
impressionnant franchement et même un
peu ardent incandescent natendezv que
vous signez chez Albin Michel une Albin
Michel c'est une méditation
philosophique une forme de traversée la
vôtre en forme de rupture on va voir
cela dans l'invitation de Clément
perouau interview juste
après
si on vous invite Nathan deevert c'est
pour parler du doute et en particulier
de vos doutes votre parcours Briant ne
semble pourtant pas y laisser place
Nathan de vert vous êtes né en
1997 26 ans seulement normalien agrégé
de philosophie et déjà C ouvrages
publiés et une certaine notoriété
télévisuelle vous êtes chroniqueur
régulier sur C news avec Pascal pro sur
France 3 chez Michel Drucker mais aussi
chez nous à LCP dans notre émission vous
regarde pourtant derrière cette belle
vitrine se cache une histoire à la fois
tourmentée et lumineuse que vous
racontez dans votre dernier livre penser
contre soi-même Nathan de ver vous avez
grandi dans une famille juive d'otteuil
avec un rêve en tête de venir Rabin
toute votre vie tournait autour de la
religion elle en était le sens et
l'explication tout dormant et déjà
debout dans les idées je m'éjectais d'un
coup de mon matelas prière du réveil
ablution des mains trois pages de
bénédiction matinale douche expéditive
20 minutes à peine séparé l'ouverture de
mes yeux du moment où je sortais dans la
rue la tête remplie d'ardeur et le cœur
plein d'Allan quel prodige quand j'y
repense et puis Nathan de ver vous avez
douter dter au point de perdre la foi et
de vous passionner pour les livres et
surtout pour la philosophie notamment
l'œuvre de Martin Heidegger finalement
vous avez commis une forme de suicide
existentiel vous avez remis en cause
tout ce qui constituait votre identité
supposée naissance famille origine
sociale et religieuse une mise à nu
totale qui détonne dans notre époque de
certitude où les opinions n'ont jamais
semblé aussi arrêté ou penser contre
soi-même est presque une anomalie Platon
le décrivait déjà dans le myth de la
caverne c'était déjà ça mais aujourd'hui
on y est à fond et on le voit tous les
jours mais que en fait quand on ne pense
pas contre soi-même on ne pense pas du
tout ça veut dire qu'on est juste la
marionnette intellectuelle de son
identité de c'est-à-dire de choses qui
sont des conditionnements des
déterminations ça crée une situation où
le débat public en fait est nul a une
impossibilité tout simplement à la fois
de dialoguer et de questionner alors
comment faire revivre ce débat public
penser contre soi-même est-ce une
traversée exclusivement individuelle ou
peut-elle être
collective réponse est-ce que cette
traversée elle s'apprend est-ce que
c'est la tâche même de la philosophie
est-ce que ça peut devenir un projet
politique je dira c'est d'abord et avant
tout une une traversée qui doit être
opérée à l'échelle individuelle parce
que c'est une épreuve de de solitude
penser contre soi-même c'est essayer de
prendre une certaine forme de distance
par rapport à son identité par rapport à
ce qu'on croyait être soi auquel on peut
s'accrocher se dire finalement mon Soi
enfin mon moi je ne l'ai pas tellement
choisi tout a été plus ou moins dessiné
sans moi et et donc ça suppose une
solitude par rapport à soi-même donc ça
c'est profondément individuel là où ça
devient collectif c'est que c'est une
démarche qui après crée une certaine
forme de de souplesse de de manière de
décoïncider par rapport à soi-même et
donc d'ouverture à l'altérité aux autres
perspectives et donc ça ouvre une sorte
de possibilité en effet de de débat
public et de vie collective qui est
beaucoup plus souple alors c'est quand
même violent un suicide existentiel
Nathan le sceptique à liquider Nathan le
croyant est-ce que ça fait mal oui ça
fait mal la la mort de Dieu d'abord
c'est euh quand on l' ça peut être une
phrase juste de Nietzsche de dire bon
dieu est mort mais quand on le vit à la
première personne et c'est ce que j'ai
voulu raconter dans ce texte c'est pour
ça d'ailleurs que j'ai écrit à la
première personne c'était pas du tout
dans une sorte de démarche narcissique
de raconter ma vie c'est parce que je
crois pas en l'idée d'une vérité absolue
je pense que les les idées
philosophiques les questionnements ce
sont des choses qui sont incarnées et
quand j'ai cessé de croire en Dieu
c'était une expérience extrêmement
douloureuse je la compare à une sorte de
suicide alors j'ai pas de tentation
suicidaire de de supprimer ma vie
biologique mais un suicide c'est-à-dire
au sens où tout le monde dans lequel
j'habitais tout le sens de la vie qui
pour moi était absolument évident ma
manière de vivre les lois que que je
respectais tout ça s'est écroulé
quasiment du jour au lendemain alors on
va y venir à toutes ces lois vous êtes
très très jeune en fait un des 11 12 ans
quand vous décidez de plonger dans
l'étude de la Torah dans sa pratique la
plus stricte alors que vos parents
d'ailleurs vous en parlez ils sont quand
même pas du tout des pratiquants très
assidus de la religion juive est-ce
qu'il y a un déclic est-ce que c'est le
voyage à Jérusalem le déclic je dirais
que c'est une forme de quête de sens mes
parents m'ont m'ont donné une très très
très belle image de la religion ils
étudiaient enfin gens parlent ils
étudient toujours mais ils étudiaient
beaucoup les la Bible et puis le talmude
et la pensée juive en général ils
avaient une pratique traditionnaliste
mais qui m'a donné très très envie de
m'investir davantage dans la religion
parce que j'y voyais un sens et que
justement j'étais même un peu frustré
par rapport à leur pratique que je que
je jugeais insuffisante un peu trop
softe en effet en tout cas moi je
voulais y aller de manière radicaleof
alors justement pourquoi parce qu'avec
vous on sent bien qu'il y a pas de
demi-mesure dès l'enfance c'est tout ou
rien vous êtes absolutiste oui en ça
d'ailleurs je me suis pas contredit je
suis resté euh radical là-dessus c'est
vrai que je comprends pas en fait
comment on peut se dire euh qu'une
religion entre guillemets on y croit
qu'on y adhère tout en se disant je vais
choisir dedans ce qui me plaît je vais
respecter un peu comme je veux je vais
trouver mon petit équilibre personnel
là-dedans et je vais aller à la
synagogue une fois par an pour Kip pour
ou ceci ou cela et ça vous les aimez pas
les Juifs de Kipour alors ceux qu'on
appelle les Juifs de Kipour ils sont
quoi paresseux oui quand j'étais
religieux je trouvais ça un peu agaçant
je me disais mais qui sont ces gens qui
viennent 1 heure à la synagogue pour
demander pas pardon et pour retomber
dans leur vice entre guillemets enfin
mais dans leur vie une heure après ils
demandent pardon tout en sachant que
c'est un mot qui ne veut rien dire et
tout en et maintenant que j'ai pris de
la distance en tout cas si j'ai pris une
distance aussi aussi éloignée aussi
forte c'est parce que j'aurais trouvé ça
un peu irrespectueux par rapport à la
religion de continuer à la pratiquer à
moitié moi ça a été quelque chose
d'essentiel dans ma vie j'ai énormément
d'admiration pour la religion juive et
pour les autres religieuxs en soi
d'ailleurs et je trouverai ça hypocrite
un peu tartuf de continuer si vous
voulez à faire ça à la car alors il faut
bien comprendre pour ceux qui ne
connaissent pas la religion juive que
quand on y va à fond comme vous et bien
ça nécessite d'abord de se passionner
pour les texte pour le talmude les
interprétations mais pas seulement c'est
aussi des lois vous dites que vous
l'acceptiez vous vous sentiez léger sous
un monceau de loi et il y en a
énormément vous priez trois fois par
jour vous respectez le shabbat vous n'z
n plus l'électricité vous racontez même
et c'est très drôle que parce qu'on n'
pas le droit de déchirer vous préparez
vos petits paquets de pépier toilette
pour que à Chabbat vous ne soyez pas
dans le péché mais c'est de la
contrainte pur et vous vous respirez
dans la contrainte exactement alors on
dit souvent juif orthodoxe pour dire
désigner le juifs religieux c'est faux
il y a pas d'orthodoxie d'opinion droite
chez les Juifs il y a une une pensée qui
est très libre en revanche il y a une
orthopraxie c'est le judaïsme a ça en
commun avec l'islam d'estimer que le
rapport à Dieu passe pas tellement par
l'amour par la grâce et cetera mais
passe par le respect absolu et total de
la loi ce qui est une manière presque
même de se protéger contre l'idolâtrie
je ne sais pas trop à quoi ressemble
Dieu mais je sais qu'il y a des lois que
je dois respecter et donc c'est des lois
vous vous l'avez dit c'est du du moment
où on ouvre ses yeux le matin jusqu'au
moment où on les ferme le soir en
passant par la manière dont on va lasser
ses chaussures les interdits
alimentaires plein d'obligations des
heures et des heures de prièr par jour
mais ça a des conséquences sur la vie de
famille alors c'est ça vous dites même
je suis devenu un boulet pour ma famille
sauf que votre famille elle vous
respecte elle vous laisse faire ce choix
oui c'est vrai moi j'aim j'aimis
beaucoup tout ça parce que bon moi
j'étais pas du tout proséite j'étais
très évidemment tolérant enfin j'avais
pas de leçons à donner à mes parents de
toutes les manières mais eux aussi
étaient très sympathique et tolérant par
rapport à au fait que je je pratiquais
et donc c'était assez marrant parce que
j'étais un juif très orthopraxe mais
dans un univers que ce soit avec mes
parents ou que ce soit quand j'étais à
l'école publique qui n'était pas du tout
celui-ci et donc il y avait une forme de
solitude dans la pratique de la religion
mais que j'aimais que j'aimais beaucoup
alors on va arriver sur la rupture mais
il y a des scènes c'est ça qui est aussi
très intéressant c'est vraiment de la
littérature c'est très bien écrit dans
ce livre racontez-nous l'ignau une
communauté de Juifs d'Afrique du Nord
dans le quartier d'ôuteuil que vous avez
fréquenté c'est quoi vous vous retrouvez
avec des octogéires oui l était un
endroit génial qui est une synagogue
sans Rabin donc une synagogue où tout le
monde peut plus ou moins un peu
s'improviser Rabin et on y allait une
fois vraiment par an à quiip pour et et
moi c'était un endroit qui me fascinait
et puis un matin je me suis pointé là à
l'aube à la prière du matin en semaine
et alors là il y avait plein
d'octogénèes ou en tout cas de retraités
qui qui qui voit un petit gosse
débarquer ici ils se disent mais
qu'est-ce que c'est que ça il a dû se
tromper de porte et ils m'ont adopté ils
m'ont fait une sorte de je suis devenu
un peu entre guillemets leur leur
mascottes ils sont devenus ma deuxième
famille et j'adorais moi aller à la
synagogue le matin être avec tous ces
gens qui étaient absolument formidables
extrêmement drôle enfin on rigolait
énormément et puis ils étaient
extrêmement touchants parce qu'ils
avaient à la fois toute la culture
notamment marocaine dans les chants dans
la liturgie toute la culture juive dans
l'étude et toute la culture évidemment
aussi française et après j'allais à
l'école et j'adorais être comme ça à
cheval entre une vie de collégien
sympathique normale et euh toute cette
autre identité la rupture alors comment
s'opert-t-elle à 18 ans alors que vous
préparez à entrer dans une école
rabinique parce que vous voulez
ardemment devenir Rabin il y a la
lecture d'un texte en particulier euh
qui va commencer à ébranler toutes vos
certitudes exactement on m'avait demandé
de faire un cours sur sur l'Ecclésiaste
et je lis l'Ecclésiaste et ce texte me
me boulevere parce que je pense qu'il y
a peu de textes qui sont assez allés
aussi loin dans la manière de brûler
attaquer de contredire toutes les
illusions de la vie pas seulement les
illusions intellectuelles cette phrase
très connue qui commence l'Ecclésiaste
vanité des vanités tout n'est que vanité
et puis ensuite tout ce texte là où le
l'auteur qui s'appelle coelette raconte
tous les aspects de la vie qu'il a connu
le plaisir qu'il a connu la connaissance
et cetera mais que tout ça n'abolit pas
la la la vanité et j'ai eu l'impression
que c'était un livre qui de l'intérieur
de la Bible la faisait exploser h il y a
cette scène inaugurale qui est très
belle le jour de Kipour où vous
comprenez qu'il n'y a défin ivement plus
rien de religieux en vous racontez la
nous c'est une scène complètement dingue
mon éditeur pensait que je l'avais
inventé mais je l'ai vraiment vécu comme
ça je donne cours à l'université à
Bordeaux en début d'année mon cours se
passe très bien je devais dormir à
Bordeaux donc j'avais pris une petite
chambre d'hôtel mais un peu moche mais
j'aime bien ce genre de d'hôtel comme ça
et et et et et tout au long de la
journée j'appelle des proches mes
parents et personne me répond et je je
n'y pense pas trop mais tous les
téléphones sont sont éteints et quand
j'arrive dans ma chambre d'hôtel après
avoir bu de trois ver de
je j'allume une cigarette dans la cour
intérieure et en face il y avait un
appartement et une femme juive très
belle qui chante et qui fait la prière
de Kipour que je reconnais tout de suite
et j'avais oublié que c'était Kip pour
sachant que tous les Juifs du monde même
les plus
assimilés pratiquent un peu Kip pour ou
alors quand ils sont provocateurs et
qu'il veulent aller manger du cochon ils
le font parce qu'ils savent que c'est
Kip pour mais oubliez que c'est Kip pour
c'est vraiment le stade ultime et là il
y a eu un moment comme ça et je me suis
mis à écrire ce texte à peu près à ce
moment-là il y a forcément de la perte
dans cette rupture est- est-ce qu'il y a
une part de cette vie d'avant qui vous
manque
aujourd'hui alors en un sens oui un peu
c'estàd enfin je pense que j'aurais été
beaucoup plus facilement heureux si
j'avais été Rabin au sens où j'aurais
vécu dans un monde dont le sens ne
m'aurait pas trop posé problème j'aurais
su qu'elle était ce ce sens-l donc oui
mais écrire ce livre m'a réconcilié
quand même enfin je me suis remis à
l'hébreu je me suis remis même même pour
l'écrire j'ai relu beaucoup la Bible et
cetera et et et donc tout l'aspect de
rupture même de un peu violent
c'est un peu atténué au profit de l'idée
d'un voyage d'un voyage sans destination
d'une avancée d'une errrance d'ailleurs
vouses vous romp avec la religion mais
pas avec le judaïsme je voudrais qu'on
dise un mot sur la nature même de ce
texte vous parlez de rêverie de
méditation c'est c'est pas de
l'autofiction vous dites jeu vous citez
le nom de vos parents le célèbre
neurologue Lionel nakchee d'ailleurs
vous appelez Nathan nakche et Karine
nakach votre mère et et et en même temps
il y a un tout petit peu de liberté
notamment avec la chronologie avec
certains personnages je pense au au
Rabin qui n'existe pas et qui s'appelle
cot Mel oui alors quand quand j'avais
écrit des romans parfois il y a des gens
qui me disaient bon mais tes personnages
évidemment c'est toi tu tu raconté ta
vie je disais non non vraiment pas et et
je enfin pour moi un roman c'est une
œuvre vraiment d'imagination pure et là
de la même manière j'ai pas voulu
tricher donc ça veut dire les faits que
je raconte je les raconte tel quel je
change pas les noms j'ai pas romancé en
revanche je voulais que la la durée la
tempor ité des événements soit fictive
ça veut dire que je puisse raconter
avant un événement qui a eu lieu après
et réciproquement pourquoi parce que
l'ordre dans lequel les événements
surviennne dans notre vie est un ordre
complètement arbitraire complètement
chaotique qui n'a pas de sens en
lui-même et en effet ce livre je voulais
que ce soit une sorte de de méditation
de méditation au sens vraiment classique
du terme ça veut dire un livre qui
essaie de faire de la philosophie mais
de manière incarnée mais de manière
subjective précisément parce qu'il y a
pas de vérité absolu que nos existences
sont des quêtes et donc à partir de là
je voulais que le que qu'il y ait quand
même cette part-l de de de de fiction ou
en tout cas de d'une écriture dont la
durée est eff fictive merci beaucoup une
toute petite dernière question vous qui
avez porter la kipa même dans la rue
vous racontez d'ailleurs l'antisémitisme
que vous avez perçu dans les rues de de
Paris est-ce qu'on peut encore penser
contre soi-même après le 7 octobre c'est
très difficile mais je pense qu'on peut
et je pense même qu'on doit en un sens
merci beaucoup Nathan de verre vous avez
compris LCP recommande chaudement cette
méditation qui n'a rien d'égocentrique
et c'est aux éditions Albin Michel allez
c'est l'heure des affranchis vous allez
pouvoir réagir c'est vous qui allez
réagir à la place du grand témoin cette
fois on les accueille tout de
suite Bertrand Perrier qui va nous
surprendre ce soir avec son billet sur
le le théâtre à l'école la sémiologue
Mariette darigrand installez-vous et
meilleur vœux pour 2024 parce que je
vous ai pas vu jusqu'à présent on
commence avec action planè la chronique
écolo de Léa Falco bonsoir Léa bonsoir
alors ce soir vous nous parlez de de
l'avenir des sport SP d'iver et de
l'avenir des stations de ski et oui
parce que depuis les années 70 on
constate une baisse de l'enigement et on
considère que à chaque degré de
réchauffement climatique supplémentaire
on perdra en France à peu près un mois
d'enneigement donc évidemment pour toute
l'économie des sports divhivers ça pose
la question de l'adaptation on a en
Europe plus de 2200 stations et la
grande majorité risque d'être menacé
dans quelques décennies et en
particulier évidemment celles qui sont
en basse ou en moyenne montagne la neige
artificielle c'est une alternative c'est
une des alternatives qui existe donc
comment est-ce que ça marche on projette
de l'eau par température négative et
avant qu'elle atteigne le sol elle se
cristallise en cristau de glace et donc
quand ça tombe pouf ça vous fait de la
neige artificielle le principe est
pratique mais dans les fess ça utilise
beaucoup d'énergie et beaucoup d'eau qui
pourrait être géré autrement par exemple
je prends juste l'exemple de l'eau un
hectare de neige artificiel ça demande
par an environ 4000 m C d'eau c'est
l'équivalent d'une piscine olympique si
on regarde la grande la grande image on
a besoin pour la neige artificielle en
France par an de 28 millions mè cubes
d'eau ça nous dit pas grand chose comme
ça mais en fait c'est la consommation en
eau de 500000 personnes quand même demi
milillion de personnes donc c'est pas
rien c'est des chiffres qui en plus sont
en augmentation et quand vous mettez 1
lre d'eau dans un canon à neige vous
avez environ 30 à 40 % qui disparaît
dans le processus c'est-à-dire qu' ne
revient pas à l'état naturel
immédiatement donc derrière le modèle de
la neige artificielle il y a quand même
vraiment cette question qui est comment
est-ce qu'on gère la répartition de la
ressource en eau et puis en regardant un
peu plus loin on se dit que si
aujourd'hui on manque de neige on a un
problème pour les stations mais que si
demain on manque d'eau celles qui se
sont tourné vers la neige artificielle
vont connaître le même problème donc
est-ce que vous recommandez qu'on ferme
tout simplement ces stations de ski bah
la question de la fermeture elle est
intéressante parce que le ski il est
symptommatique en fait de la relation
qu'en tant que société on entretient
avec l'adaptation au réchauffement
climatique c'est-à-dire que on a des
choses qui se raréfient voire
disparaissent et à côté on doit réussir
à gérer cette raréfaction sans pour
autant que ce soit une catastrophe
sociale pour les gens qui vivent de ces
activités là donc dans la question du
ski il y a plusieurs modèles il y a des
stations qui réfléchissent carrément à
sortir complètement du ski comme la
station juracienne de metabiefief et il
y en a d'autres qui veulent diversifier
leur modèle considérer qu'il faut sortir
du tout ski et adopter ce qu'on appelle
le modèle 4 saisons donc ouverture toute
l'année autour de d'activités VTT
randonnée et ski quand c'est possible
l'hiver c'est un modèle qui est un petit
peu compliqué économiquement parce que
le ski c'est particulièrement pour ur
d'emploi et de revenus ce qui est
beaucoup moins le modèle des quatre
saisons donc c'est une c'est vraiment un
champ qui est en pleine réflexion mais
c'est surtout un déchirement affectif en
fait pour les pour les habitants de ces
régions là qui vivent du ski et du
tourisme donc il y a la vraie question
de comment est-ce que on fait pour
accompagner tous ces acteurs là tous ces
gens-là qui se retrouvent malgré eux
dans un cul de sac économique et
écologique et comment est-ce qu'on fait
surtout pour réfléchir à faire autrement
sans pour autant s'encharner dans des
modèles qui ne fonctionnent plus on va y
arriver natend vert on en prend pas le
chemin avec les gos d'h c'est une vra
question en France mais on a les
paysages mais il va falloir faire
autrement mais vous avez raison c'est un
déchirement affectif c'est là qu'on voit
que le réchauffement climatique c'est
pas seulement quelque chose que
décrivent les scientifiques avec des
chiffres qu'on voit tous enfin je pas
énormément la montagne mais c'est vrai
que en 26 ans j'ai pu voir des des
endroits que je connais où on voit qu'il
y a une évolution une perte de neige et
puis un désespoir des des habitants qui
qui est absolument terrible oui mais il
y a les qure saisons hein et on oui de
la montagne c'est sûr qu' voit Bertrand
alors vous me surprenez ce soir euh
qu'est-ce que vous pensez de la
proposition présidentielle le théâtre
passage obligé je cite désormais au
collège dès la rentrée prochaine dans le
principe on ne peut qu'être d'accord
tout le monde connaît les vertus du
théâtre pour la formation des jeunes
gens elles sont multiples la première
c'est évidemment une vertu patrimoniale
c'est le contact avec les grands textes
avec les grands dramaturge la deuxième
vertu c'est évidemment une vertu de
pratique collective c'est aussi l'écoute
c'est une pratique que l'on fait avec
d'autres c'est une pratique de
l'interaction et puis évidemment j'y
suis sensible c'est l'oralité c'est un
corps dans l'espace c'est une voix que
l'on projette c'est un peu de confiance
en soi un peu d'image de soi dont on a
tant besoin quand on est adolescent et
puis c'est aussi la créativité c'est
aussi la sensibilité et à tout cela on
ne peut évidemment qu'être sensible
alors vous avez des doute pourtant c'est
davantage sur les conditions dans
lesquelles ces cours de théâtre vont
être fait oui parce que ce passage
obligé l'expression est assez abstraite
et on n'est pas allé beaucoup au-delà et
moi j'ai plusieurs questions évidemment
la première question c'est qui enseigne
le théâtre il y a som tout très peu
d'enseignant oui alors tout le monde a
beaucoup ri sur les souvenirs personnels
je crois qu'il faut évidemment aller
au-delà mais en effet qui enseigne il y
a très peu d'enseignants qui sont
spécialement formés au cours de théâtre
et donc il faudra faire appel à des
intervenants extérieurs à des comédiens
à des troupes avec quel budget selon
quelle fréquence deuxème question quel
volume horaire on est obsédé à l'idée de
renforcer les savoirs fondamentaux et on
disperse de nouveau en créant de
nouvelles disciplines alors est-ce qu'on
va renier sur quelque chose est-ce qu'on
va ajouter à un emploi du temps qui est
déjà très chargé 2è question 3è question
quel programme quel contenu quelle pièce
quelle évaluation s'il faut évaluer les
enfants là-dessus et puis la dernière
chose qui est probablement l'essentiel
c'est quels effectifs qui fait cours de
théâtre à une classe de 30 élèves c'est
absolument impossible et on a un peu
l'impression que le Président de la
République vit dans le monde qui a connu
c'est-à-dire celui de l'option théâtre
que choisissait un petit nombre d'élèves
qui aimait ça qui était volontaire qui
éta dynamique était motivé mais à partir
du moment où passe sur un autre modèle
qui est celui de l'obligation où tous
les élèves doivent suivre c'est une
autre organisation et il faut gérer les
élèves perturbateurs il faut gérer les
élèves très réticents et ça ça bon
courage aux enseignants qui s'en
chargeront en somme c'est une fausse
bonne idée pour vous non ça peut-être
une vraie bonne idée mais c'est une
bonne idée qui requier une mise en œuvre
très particulière avec du temps avec du
budget en somme la pièce est bien écrite
mais on attend la mise en scène merci
beaucoup Bertrand Perrier pour ce
partiprix gadget le le théâtre
obligatoire non mais je me demande à
vous écoutant si on pourrait pas enfin
intégrer la l'oralité peut-être pas le
théâtre mais l'oralité dans des cours
comme la littérature et la philosophie
parce que évidemment découvrir un texte
à l'oral on pense je sais pas découvrir
Céline lu par podalides ou par Luini il
y a deux écoles je préfère podalides
mais mais c'est extraordinaire et ça n'a
absolument rien à voir avec le lire on
pourrait imaginer quelque chose comme ça
mais ce serait pas vraiment du théâre
alors là il faudrait que vous formiez
pas mal de de personnels avec élo dire
sur ce que dit Nathan en réalité cette
formation à la théâtralité trouve son
prolongement dans le grand oral du
baccalauréat où pour le coup l'élève est
moteur de sa propre épreuve il choisit
son sujet et là il va trouver ses
propres mots et ses propres convictions
là en eff fait dans ce que dit Nathan on
est un peu à mi-chemin finalement on est
dans le texte mais dans sa lecture ou
dans sa déclamation qui est à mi-chemin
presque entre le la théâtralité
collective et et le grand oral que l'on
crée soi-même c'est presque un sujet de
débat tiens l'oralité le théâtre on va y
réfléchir pour la semaine prochaine
Mariette conférence de presse
présidentielle oblige le mot de la
semaine c'estette autorité oui on a eu
un pic cette semaine avec ce mot il a
été beaucoup prononcé autour de la
question de justement de l'école de
l'éducation mais enfin je dirais que
dans notre série politico-médiatique
c'est un personnage récurrent ça revient
très très souvent ça donne envie
d'imiter Flobert vous savez dans son
Dictionnaire des idées reçues j'ai
vérifié le mot autorité n'y est pas mais
on pourrait avoir autorité de points la
rétablir d'urgence parce que il faut
toujours toujours la la refaire c'était
beaucoup mieux avant avec ce concept
alors autant aller voir dans cet avant
qu'est-ce qu'on a dans cet avant Miriam
on a un sens complètement commercial en
fait autorité le sens premier c'est
augmenter la valeur d'un bien quand on
vend un terrain ou une maison donc celui
qui a de l'autorité c'est celui qui vous
dit mon bien vaut mieux que tu ne le
penses donc on est dans un marchandage
une forme de Deal complètement et c'est
là-dessus que j'avais envie de
d'éclairer le mot avec ça parce que on
on en a une vision un peu
comportementale et noble l'autorité
c'est quelqu'un qui arrive justement de
manière un peu théâtrale et terré non
c'est d'abord celui justement qui
marchande
alors c'est important d'avoir ça en tête
parce que c'est comme ça que le mot se
développe sens 1 c'est le marchandage et
s sens 2 c'est le marchandage de son
influence intéressant c'est-à-dire que
celui qui a de l'autorité c'est celui
qui a beaucoup d'influence sur les
autres c'est justement cette dimension
d'autorité influence que les professeurs
ont bien du mal à exercer aujourd'hui
bah les pauvres ils vivent auutant des
influenceurs c'est quand même très
difficile pour un professeur d'avoir une
parole qui aura autant d'influence
autant de poids sur ses élèves qui sont
sensibles à de tous autres codes donc ça
c'est la mauvaise nouvelle bien sûr on
connaît les problèmes je vais essayer d'
d'en voir une bonne d'en voir une bonne
c'est une autre aspiration dans notre
société qui est d'être augmenté vous
savez l'homme augmenté c'est pas
seulement le cyborg avec de la technique
c'est aussi vouloir soi-même avoir plus
de talent avoir plus de compétences
pourquoi bah pour avoir plus de valeur
dans notre société marchande donc
gardons en tête cette idée parce que
évidemment on peut déplorer ça et
regretter l'instituteur à la
Camu voyez he ce qu' a dit Camu le
professeur qui m'a donné tant avec tant
de dévotion de gratuité oui d'ailleurs
il y a des tas de professeurs qui sont
encore dans ce schéma il y a une
générosité pédagogique dans notre pays
merci faut pas l'oublier dieu merci mais
si on pousse cette valeur marchande au
bout on trouve quelque chose
d'intéressant je trouve je parle sous le
contrôle de Nathan de ver philosophe
Anna arent a bien expliqué que
l'autorité euh était en lien avec la
transmission culturelle on ne peut pas
se déclarer autoritaire euh si on n pas
cette transmission sinon on un despot
justement alors poussons l'idée c'est un
capital culturel ça qui est en jeu
aujourd'hui dans notre société de
marchandage et même de Deal vous avez
raison myiam et bien pourquoi ce capital
culturel ne pourrait pas être pris aussi
dans une forme de Deal après tout à quoi
ça va me servir comme disent les enfants
ça sert à quoi bah à avoir du diplôme à
avoir de l'argent à avoir et cetera
voilà donc ça je trouve que c'est
intéressant et donc qu'on soit très
matérialiste ou pas du tout matérialiste
en tout cas ce qui ne marche pas c'est
l'autorité de surface c'est-à-dire la
grosse voie qui gronde et le petit doigt
sur la couture de l'uniforme merci
beaucoup Mariette retrouver l'idée qu'on
a quelque chose à gagner de l'autorité
ça vous parle oui c'est c'est
extrêmement intéressant je trouve dans
le débat public aujourd'hui quand on
parle beaucoup d' en effet rétablir
l'autorité c'est on a un concept de
l'autorité comme intimidation et c'est
vraiment ça dans tous les domaines alors
que vous le montré très très bien
l'autorité c'est avant tout l'admiration
et une admiration qui doit être quelque
chose de de légitime l'autorité c'est
presque un concept libertaire quand
quand on quand on le pousse jusqu'à son
son paroxisme comme vous l'avez fait si
on estime que c'est celui qui va me
transmettre quelque chose c'est au
contraire celui qui m'apporte de la
liberté et pas du tout celui qui va me
crier dessus avec sa grosse voix et qui
peut me menacer allez on s'arrête là
excellente émission grâce à vous les
affranchis merci Léa Bertrand Mariette
et Merci à VOUS Nathan de vert penseer
contre soi-même c'est donc chez Alb
Michel c'est le le weekend profitez bien
si vous pouvez souffler bien sûr à la
semaine prochaine très belle soirée sur
[Musique]
LCP